hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number 171 which I
feel certain must be prime because what
the hell are you going to divide into it
I forgot to look yeah but it just
doesn't it feel so very Prime
I'm I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna take
the risk I'm just gonna predict that it
is and if anybody can figure out factors
I'd love to know what they are
um all right I am Dr Brett Weinstein you
remain Dr Heather Hein we are here to
discuss the important issues of the day
the future should there be one and uh we
are gonna we're gonna head that
direction very very soon yeah we are um
we're coming to you early today it's
just occurred to me you said I remain Dr
Heather high and I was thinking well
I was a highing assigned before birth
I was assigned Heather at Birth
yeah I was assigned doctor much later
but there was never any assignment of my
sex because that's just what I am
no no there was an obstetrician involved
I feel certain of it just ask your mom
I I that doesn't matter no well all
right my mom matters my mom it's my
mom's birthday today happy birthday
happy birthday Jesse
um but the the fact the obstetrician
being there and observing something uh
verifiably true about the universe uh
does why why would we uh give the
obstetrician more power than they
actually have in uh in pretending why
would we pretend that they are uh in
charge of reality they're not so what
you're saying is you had an old school
obstetrician the kind that observes the
universe as if that's a thing I have no
idea I really have no memory of the day
yes that's probably true yeah and for
the best oh for sure for sure hi
everyone uh this is live stream 171 and
um yeah we're gonna make it uh short and
sweet today apologies for coming to you
earlier than we had uh we had said we
would uh next week we will be coming to
you rather later than usual by about
um three days three days in a few hours
we'll be coming to you excuse me Tuesday
May wow Tuesday May 9th uh and I can't
remember what when we decided 2 p.m
maybe Pacific something like that um but
here we are today no q a today uh but if
you are looking for more uh for more
Dark Horse content while we are away uh
the conversation that you had with Mary
Harrington
is is up and that was released right
before our previous live stream we've
been getting a lot of great feedback on
that seem to love it yep and um and of
course there are there are other uh
guest episodes uh that you've you've
done that we have generally failed to uh
mention here Jeremy riss uh UFO
specialist
um yeah yep and uh and I of course
always put things out on Natural
Selections so our producer are now 19
year old son Zach is freaking out
because there's unexpected noise
happening and I have I have news for him
it's Birds
it's Birds because after all they are in
fact real and they're singing because
it's spring which we're going to talk
about just a little bit at the end of
the hour today ornithologist real yes
some of them are crappy
well some birds are crappy too people
are crappy yeah I don't know why
Ornithology should be an exception to
the rule that precisely yes uh you know
but I don't want to believe all
ornithologists any more than I want to
believe all anyone I'll believe all
ornithologists that would be a thing yep
it's a niche although honestly if I had
if I if we have to pick a demographic by
you know by either profession or
immutable characteristic or whatever I
feel like a a niche a small Niche
purportedly scientifically trained group
like ornithologists I I'd go with them
sooner than I go with say doctors at
this pathological confusions are
unlikely to be immediately harmful
maybe the birds possibly right right or
I guess you could get salmonella if you
eat chicken yeah and when birds get uh
you know misidentified or misgendered
God forbid uh guess what the birds don't
care because birds are like that's your
language doesn't pertain to us
okay word Brands very different from
you know other kinds of Brands they're
actually they have like like is true for
uh like is more generally true between
mammals and birds you know this already
um they are not each of these closest
relatives the most recent common
ancestor birds and mammals was some stem
reptile because birds are descendants of
dinosaurs which are reptiles
um but birds and mammals have a
tremendous amount of convergence between
them and some of that happens in the
brains but the part of our brain that's
so gigantic are are um our cortex is a
different and different part of the
brain that's been enlarged a part of the
brain that was primitively associated
with a smell whereas the part of the
brain that is enlarged for Birds was
proudly associated with vision two
points of order one there are certain
birds that have excellent senses of
smell but they are very much the
exceptional and there are certain things
mammals that have excellent senses of
vision like premise like like us yes
second point of clarification stem had
not been invented in the age of reptiles
capitalize differently got it all right
well one's a word one's an acronym I'm
glad we took care of that yeah I'm not
at all okay why should they be any
different than any other no that's not
that's not how it is okay
um
in Natural Selections this last week I
actually posted uh some things from a
long ago program that I taught at
Evergreen and got some some fun and
interesting feedback because for um uh
the the second of the two things I
posted was was a bunch of the questions
that I posed as part of the curriculum
to my first year students and
um
you know without of course providing the
lectures the readings you know all of
the material that went along with those
questions but I really love to see the
conversation on Natural Selections about
those questions and what what kinds of
things it prompted people to think about
so I encourage you to go take a look if
you haven't that's of course natural
selections.substack.com
we have the store where you can get all
sorts of cool stuff
um and we are supported by you our
audience Please Subscribe if you've been
unsubscribed by YouTube how dare they
they do that a lot
um but re-subscribe subscribe on Odyssey
uh we have the main channel the clips
Channel please share whatever you feel
like sharing and also consider joining
us on either of our patreons where we do
private monthly q and A's and and
private conversations and also you can
join the Discord server uh with lots of
fun things happening there at either of
our patreons and of course we have
sponsors uh each show we start uh the
top of the show with three ads for
sponsors that we actually truly vouch
for and uh here we go
this week it's seed uncruise new to us
this week and have some macadamias seed
is our first sponsor probiotic that
actually works your gut and your immune
system work together coordinating your
body's response to the world both around
and within you
see it helps improve the health of your
gut microbiome which means that it
supports you becoming healthier overall
once you decide to take seed though how
will you remember to do so try habit
stacking perhaps build a major habit by
starting small I have it stacked by
keycaping excuse me keeping a sentence a
day Journal by the side of my bed I see
it every night and it's a low bar to
write a single sentence if you take seed
first thing in the morning leave the jar
in the bathroom counter each night so
it's the first thing you see when you
get up just a little hint to remind you
how if you decide that you want to take
it how to remember but why should you
take it in the first place seeds ds01
daily symbiotic is a plant-based
Prebiotic and probiotic with 24 strains
that have been clinically or
scientifically studied for their
benefits sixteen of those 24 strains are
specifically geared towards Digestive
Health as you would expect from a
probiotic and four of the 24 probiotic
strains are known to promote healthy
skin your skin like your gut has its own
microbiome seed supports both gut and
skin health
seed is free from 14 major classes of
allergens including but not limited to
sugar animal products
glyphosate Dairy shellfish and corn
quite a list and seed is basically
double hauled with its capsule in Castle
design this is this is the thing that in
my mind makes a particularly distinct
among in a vast array of probiotics it
is engineered to maintain viability
through a digestive tract until it
reaches your colon where you want it the
same design makes it resistant to oxygen
moisture and heat meaning that a
refrigeration is necessary so if you
take probiotics before and have had no
effect it's probably because your
stomach was doing what it's supposed to
do and dismantling it meaning that what
you were trying to get into your large
intestine never got there
you take two capsules once a day on
empty stomach this could be the first
thing in the morning 30 minutes before
your first meal or two hours after your
last meal seeds daily symbiotic supports
got skin and heart health and
micronutrient synthesis we have heard
from several people who have used C and
Report improvements to digestive
function 24 to 48 hours so start a new
healthy habit today visit c.com
barkhorse and use code Dark Horse to
redeem 25 off your first month of C's
DSi 1 data symbiotic that's seed.com
course and use code Darkhorse at
checkout
okay
what apparently
restart the audio we are going to be
blanking out for a few seconds here we
will be back in a second with better
audio
is better sorry about the interruption
okay we're in the middle middle of our
sponsors
uh we just heard about seed and now
uncrews our second sponsor this week is
brand new to us uncrews small ship
Adventures uncruise explores by sea and
by land they have boats that hold orders
of magnitude fewer people than most
cruise boats and they take their
passengers to some of the world's most
magnificent places Panama and Costa Rica
Galapagos the Sea of Cortez in Mexico
Alaska even right here in our backyard
the San Juan Islands
the small boats of uncrews allow
passengers to get real deep experience
their largest boat can accommodate a
mere 86 guests their smallest holds only
22. these trips aren't about dress codes
or Glitz people cram cheek to jail
unable to experience anything about
where they are
we weren't sure when they approached us
because we obviously have very high
standards about about where we go and
what claims are made by various tour
operators so we talked with CEO Dan
Blanchard the CEO of uncruise and we
were incredibly impressed with his
background his story and his ethos his
boats take small groups of people to
places that larger boats can't get to
and the excursions are designed to bring
people into deep nature without
destroying it we talked about the value
of wild roadless nature about the
environmental destruction that much much
of the cruise industry causes about
exploration and about observation this
is a kindred spirit and he's running
what appears to be a really excellent
operation
our travel standards are as I said very
high in part because we've created and
led trips to many of the places that
uncruise goes and we've seen firsthand
that most tourists do not meet
expectations our hopes are extremely
high for uncruise though and we'll know
more soon one of their itineraries goes
to Glacier Bay National Park trip the
national park in Alaska where each day
offers possibilities to kayak or explore
in a skiff or hike an old growth forest
or glacial outwash Fields there's a lot
more time on land with uncrews than with
these these Mega ships that again hold
orders of magnitude more people than
these boats do
uncruise understands that the boat is
just a tool there's small ship cruises
take guests through communities cultures
and locales on the ground so they can
have actual experiences and every
sailing with uncruises all-inclusive
Transportation drinks Farm to Table
Cuisine daily excursions are all
included
uncrews uncruise is giving Dark Horse
listeners a fantastic deal 500 off their
current cruises an offer that you can
combine with other savings including
their last minute to Spring and Alaska
trips which are already discounted so
you can you can hire all these uh this
deal on top of their other deals going
on right now so start planning your next
trip with uncrews today and take
advantage of our great offer go now to
uncrews.com Pages slash Darkhorse
remember to save 500 on your trip go now
to uncrews.com Pages slash Darkhorse
once more that's uncrews.com Pages slash
Darkhorse to receive 500 off
any cruise that they do you can tell
it's a very different kind of cruise
because on the list of equipment that
they have you compile rubber boots
that's right yeah you're in dear to war
heart I again I'm I having you know we
both ran a lot of domestic
um
uh field trips and I ran a number of
study abroad trips and the packing list
especially for study abroad are
incredibly important uh especially when
you're going into places where there is
no Commerce and uh you won't be able to
buy things that you're missing and the
vast majority if not all of the people
you are going with have never been into
places like this before and so when I
looked at their packing list I I felt
again a kindred spirit I thought okay
these people both know what they're
doing and
um are actually doing uh what they say
they're doing else they wouldn't bother
asking people to bring along all of this
type of gear yeah absolutely very
exciting all right our final sponsor
this week is House of macadamias tree
nuts are delicious and nutritious they
are generally high in fat yes and low in
carbohydrates that's good unlike what
various food pyramids and government
agencies might have led you to believe
high fat low carb foods are increasingly
understood to be both satiating and good
for you but each species of nut is
different and for many of us macadamias
are the best ain't that the truth
macadamia nuts take a very long time to
grow however and because they are both
rare and highly sought after they have
the dubious distinction of being the
world's most expensive nut
between the taste and the health
benefits though they are worth it
they have even fewer carbohydrates than
most other nuts for instance half of wet
cashews or pistachios have and
two-thirds of what almonds have which
makes them a perfect snack for breaking
a daily fast and controlling blood
glucose at some point we should do a
segment on cashews it's the craziest
thing ever
like the the biology of the biology of
cashews the
dual component fruit it's a very odd nut
that also poisons a lot of people in the
process and am I right they're closely
related to mangoes goes uh uh Anna cards
yeah yeah it's like okay cashews and
mangoes I mean yeah poisonous family
yeah absolutely
um they are right right Macadamia and
that's closely related to well they are
I wish I knew they are also uniquely
rich in omega-7s including especially
palmitolic acid I said it right an
unsaturated fat that has been linked to
Natural collagen production and fat loss
and heart health that's too many ants
but you can subtract one later they're
courteousy
giant crazy flowers oh yeah yeah okay
um and House of macadamia
I put too many ands in the sun in part
this also raises a mystery of reading
which uh we dyslexics do not understand
about the rest of you which is how do
you know how to inflect the sentence
given that you haven't gotten to the end
of it and you don't know what's coming I
mean that is what Punctuation is for
admittedly it's not perfect but that is
what punctuates but when you say not
perfect like wildly screwed up and not
in I mean like okay in Spanish at least
they put a question mark at the
beginning of the sentence so you know
it's a question yeah I mean that's the
art in writing but I also wonder if
but okay I'll hold the thought you
people that's all I gotta say no but I I
do want to get back to this as soon as
you're done here all right and House of
macadamias is intent on making this
amazing food accessible to everyone they
have partnered with more than 90 farmers
in Africa and now make one-of-a-kind
vegan keto and paleo snacks these
include their dark chocolate dipped
macadamias and a delicious assortment of
bars made with 45 macadamia nuts in
flavors including salted caramel and
chocolate coconut but our favorite
product of theirs is the simple salted
macadamias made with namibian sea salt
which I also pronounced correctly they
are amazing we love them and think that
you will too
House of macadamias also makes delicious
macadamia nut oil which is a hundred
percent cold pressed rich in
monounsaturated fatty acids and has a
higher smoke point than Olive Oil so is
well suited to high heat cooking and
baking our house of macadamias no
you tricked me our house of academia's
Highly recommends the house of
macadamias for all your macadamic needs
go to
www.house of macadamias.com and use the
code Darkhorse for 20 discount on every
order plus Dark Horse listeners will
receive a complimentary four ounce bag
of macadamias when they order three or
more boxes of any Macadamia product once
again that's
www.houseofmacademias.com use the code
Darkhorse for 20 off your order you
won't be sorry
I feel pretty good about that yeah I
feel I think I got at least a B plus on
the reading so oh you totally did so um
before before we get into the main main
topic of the show
um you asked during that read how do
non-dyslexics and flight sentences
appropriately when reading given that
you haven't gotten to the end of a
sentence yet you don't know what's
coming and my answer was well that's
what Punctuation is for that's also what
good writing is for but I also wonder if
I think that when I read certainly when
I read to myself reading out loud is is
different and then of course maybe
you're not
you still have to understand meaning but
you don't have to inflect it vocally if
you're reading to yourself of course but
I think that I scan ahead you do I I
think that I read simultaneous I'm I'm
seeing a lot of words at once and that
this is part of this is this is part of
what people who are sort of like really
immersed in writing reading you know
written written language do and it's
part of what dyslexics kind of find
baffling about the rest of us yeah no
this is this is exactly going to be my
hypothesis is that you must be a part of
you is reading ahead yeah and then your
conscious mind is wherever it is in the
sense well I mean I think this also fits
with our observation so you know a
couple months ago or so you put a number
on our we only have one camera we used
to have three that was good and so as
sort of a joke you put 17 on the One
camera we've got uh as if we had you
know anything more than a single camera
which obviously does not need to be
numbered in any way you could just be
like the camera but you put it up there
and I found it incredibly distracting
because you put text even numerals
anywhere in my visual sphere and I will
go to it I will like that's that's why
we'll Orient and I'll be constantly
trying to figure like what does that
mean why is it why is it there and uh I
you know I in turn find it baffling that
you can ignore the text in your visual
environment right and uh I having put it
there putting a prime number in a prime
location wondered why nobody had noticed
that Confluence of primes I mean it
seemed so clear and yet no but now have
you noticed that I've reversed the 17 I
told you to oh yeah no you told me to
take it off oh I did and I reversed it
yes no you reverse it right away it's
like I can't I I can't live like this
yeah right
um
yeah so
it's just backwards
the the the camera came with like I
don't know some huge number of numbers
and you could pick one and slide it in
there and I just I see I chose the 17th
but whatever
um all right shall we um move on to the
topic of the day let's do it and then
we're gonna we're gonna finish we're
gonna spend most of the time here on
what you're about to introduce here and
then we're going to talk a little bit
about spring
because it's spring here in the northern
hemisphere finally ah does it feel good
it really does all right now confession
up front I don't know exactly how to do
this what I want to do is explore a
uh a force that appears to be operating
towards some sort of objective where the
force isn't clear what it might be and
the objective isn't clear what it might
be but it's throwing paradoxes left and
right and it is worth unpacking what
this may be so
Loosely speaking the topic is
what the hell happened to Tucker Carlson
there's a paradox in that at the very
least and what does it imply about where
we are in history what what can we infer
is taking place on the basis of this
strange turn of events
now let's just recap for people who uh
may have been living under a rock and
don't know what happened is you know
whenever I use that phrase now I think I
should consider living under Iran
maybe a woman that I Skylight but a rock
living under a rock where these things
don't hit quite so hard yeah I agree
um all right so what happened is Tucker
Carlson appeared to be fired from his
Fox news programs there are more than
one
um Tucker Carlson tonight being the
biggest but uh Tucker Carlson today is
also a a daytime show and what happened
was
Tucker
was over the weekend
forbidden to return to his post so he
did a show on Friday that gave no
indication of it being uh his last show
certainly there was no indication that
he knew it was his last show and then he
did not arrive in his chair on Monday
the news having circulated that he was
fired now fired may turn out to be the
wrong term Megan Kelly reported
yesterday
that he was not fired
um but I don't I think it's a
distinction without a difference it's a
contractual question so his exit
involves a contract that we have not
seen so we don't know what what kind of
constraints foxes uh operating is
distinction without the difference if he
didn't initiate the move
I think it is very clear he did not
initiate them that's I'm saying like it
obviously
fired not fired makes a big difference
in less if you didn't initiate the move
which if that's clear then okay
distinction without a difference that's
fine he was effectively fired in the
sense that he would certainly have come
on to say what he was doing and was not
allowed to do that and they had someone
fill in for him sure okay so that
appears to be uh
a
a paradox of sorts and you and I have
said in various places I believe it's in
our book The paradoxes are a way that uh
one finds value right when there are no
real paradoxes everything has an
underlying explanation in the universe
and if you look for a place that looks
like a paradox and you dig there often
you find you learn something you didn't
know right there it's like the X on the
treasure map it's the X on the treasure
map and so there's an x on the treasure
map at the firing or de facto firing of
Tucker Carlson last week why well
because the man is whether you like him
or hate him so ferociously popular has
such an incredibly large audience
compared to competing properties
elsewhere in the mainstream media that
the idea that a conglomerate like Fox
would throw him off the air not only
cutting their connection to the source
of Rev knew that he was for them but
that they would also enrage his audience
at them
and I don't know but I would guess
that the uh
the audience of fox generally has huge
overlap with Tucker's audience he was
the biggest star on I've heard from more
than one person uh this week
the classical liberals
who had subscriptions to Fox who are
cutting him now because and and not to
punish Fox although that is a collateral
benefit but because that's why they were
there
yep that's why they were there and I
know a tremendous number of people I
wouldn't even just say classical
liberals lots and lots of people pay
attention to Tucker because in fact he
says a lot of stuff including my
personal take on it is that he is
frustrated at liberals who are failing
to make the case for their values and
although he is a died in the world
conservative
he understands that you don't want
conservatism to win that you want
conservatism to play its role you need
liberalism to play its role and that
tension requires both parties to do
their job and Liberals are falling down
on that job in favor of other nonsense
and so he has been effectively making
the case for liberalism even though it's
not his home turf which I think is
fascinating but it does mean that there
are a lot of people it reveals a kind of
Honor
it does which is another Paradox so
Paradox one why would something that is
apparently a for-profit business like
fox fire its biggest star with the
largest audience and enrage his audience
which has a huge overlap with the Rest
of Their audience and and the largest
audience with maybe the only audience at
Fox that has crossover appeal yeah right
or major crossover appeal
the second Paradox has to do with
have you ever run across the claim that
Tucker Carlson is for example a white
supremacist sure yeah you ever click
through on the evidence that finally
reveals he's finally said the quiet part
out loud no you should as much as I mean
I did uh occasionally early after
Evergreen see what the evidence that you
were uh but I I stopped doing that too
because that's pointless well I have
made a point of doing it always with
some trepidation well I will say not any
longer because I recognize the pattern
right if there's never any there but at
first like oh God what did I miss right
who is this person right so you look at
the tweet it swears that he's finally
revealed himself to be the white
supremacist that he is and then you
click through and it turns out that he
doesn't believe that our border should
be open right hardly a white supremacist
position so anyway doesn't think some
educational policies are actually good
for black people
right right right not his thing same
thing so the that was the evidence of
your white supposing
right my white supremacy for which
nobody in six years of uh there being a
bounty on my head has found any evidence
of it of course so it's the same same
old same old but here's the here's the
Paradox and I I will say
and that
I don't
this is unpleasant to recount because I
now value Tucker and know him and like
him
I did not always like him as you know
um in fact I had a visceral uh distaste
for the man that is not common for me I
don't typically find people abhorrent
and there was something very troubling
about him to me in the CNN Crossfire
days
and so I have been stuck with a question
since first interacting with him when he
in the week that Evergreen uh melted
down invited me to come on his program
and as you'll recall but I will recount
for the audience
I was reluctant
to go on his show I knew very little
about what he had been up to in modern
times a I couldn't be certain that it
wasn't a trap he and I were from
opposite sides of the political Spectrum
his team was incredibly gracious when
they reached out and I
I decided okay he seems to want to know
the story maybe that makes sense because
the story of evergreen's meltdown
reflects poorly on liberalism so I
remember this is this is one of the
conversations
from that era that I actually remember
explicitly and Visually like I know
where we had it like I know what room in
our house in Olympia we had it in and
how difficult it was uh because let's
see
Evergreen melts down at 9 30 in the
morning on a Tuesday May 23rd yeah 2017.
and I believe it's a Friday
and things have gotten crazier and worse
and everything is happening and not a
single major media Outlet
has reached out and you know we've gone
to the state house and we've tried to
get the governor to bring order to the
campus and there's just no help coming
it's getting worse and worse and worse
and his people call and you've talked to
them and
you say I think
I think I need to go on Vox and not just
Fox but Tucker and both of us are like
oh God no like why why does it why does
it have to be why isn't right why isn't
the New York Times calling why isn't CNN
calling why isn't NPR calling why aren't
all of the supposedly
left-leaning bastions of Journalism
calling at this incredibly
anti-liberal anti-democratic
Insurrection at a public College
well they weren't and they never did
and Tucker's people did
and he went on I went on and uh it was
kind of a strange thing they sent a
vehicle it's a long drive up to Seattle
from Olympia and we got stuck in traffic
so I was literally like threading the
microphone through my shirt in the
elevator they sat me down in the chair
my hair is crazy you know I I'm shiny
because nobody had any time to do makeup
because uh anyway so and you know I
couldn't see Tucker because the way this
studio is set up you're just looking at
a pair of eyeballs that have been drawn
on a piece of paper above a a camera
anyways very strange experience on the
other coast he's not he's not the same
building with you but anyway the
experience was one you know so here's
somebody I don't like who I think is
probably using me to make the case
against liberalism
um and I'm there because the story needs
to break into a larger audience they are
going to effectively snuff us out on the
campus and this Mutiny is going to take
hold of the place if I can't get the
word out and nobody else is calling so I
go there because they've offered and
there's no other place that will have me
and uh and I'm expecting him to be using
me and that's not what I got
what I got was
a compassionate guy who actually in
spite of the fact that I'm some liberal
Professor from a radical College
and this person is supposed to be my arc
political enemy
um
you know I got nothing but decency from
him and he he was not you know telling
me it's ah you see we conservatives were
right right it so anyway the second
Paradox with Tucker is that many of us
formulated an opinion of him
and then in recent times you'll find a
whole host of liberals buying Safe
Harbor on Tucker's program
you know from Glenn Greenwald who has
long been participating across uh
political divide with Tucker Matt taibi
um
Tulsi gabbard the list goes on and on
I just add a little more color to
um to your appearance there and and and
how then
that how then we live Downstream of that
while still being in you know in the
crazy part of Evergreen story uh which
was that
um
within a day or two one of the faculty
at Evergreen declared in an email to all
the faculty and staff
when Brett went on Tucker the world
shifted to the right
and I looked at that and I thought about
you know launching more things and like
I did not publicly respond but I said
but at the same time I was then
monitoring your email because you were
getting hundreds sometimes sometimes
over a thousand emails a day at that
point because it was public your
Evergreen email
and it was it it was mostly from your
appearance on tiger Carlson and and I've
spoken about this and we've written
about this before but the thing that I
saw in the people who said I saw you on
Tucker and
was amazing
and they would always begin with uh well
I'm on the right you and I disagree
politically or I'm on the left but I
listened to Tucker because or I'm in the
middle of the country or I'm in Tunisia
or I'm old I'm young I'm white I'm black
I'm female I'm male like every
demographic marker you could possibly
expect Highly Educated
um self-declared not educated at all all
of the possible demographics and yes
this is a selected group of people who
chose to write to you after seeing you
on Tucker Carlson but they said thank
you sir
you and I surely disagree about many
things maybe we don't maybe we do
but I know that if I were to meet you I
could have a conversation with you and
that is what is missing in American
discourse now and as a result of those
which continue to come in for weeks and
you know still occasionally but in just
like droves and droves and droves for
weeks I thought in response to that
confused ideologically captured faculty
member at Evergreen who had said when
Brett went on Tucker the world shifted
to the right I thought quite the
opposite quite the opposite when you
went on Tucker that opened up the world
more to the left and in in a in the good
way not the thing that is currently
masquerading as the left but in service
of conversation and frankly that is what
you learned and therefore I learned uh
Tucker Carlson was accomplishing
with with having all of these
differently uh all of these different
guests on right which then points to the
Paradox yes and I've been wondering
about this since the day that I went on
his program the first time and I think
I've been on
Dr Carlson tonight
four times and I went on Decker Crossing
today once
um so you know I've had a number of
interactions with him unfortunately the
the gig on Fox is always a few minutes
it's the hardest interview to do because
there's just no time to say anything
substantial
um but his hour-long Tucker Carlson
today thing is quite a different uh
environment and it offered the
possibility for us to interact without
the camera on you're actually there in
the studio actually physically present
and you know
I you know I know we're not in the same
place on a lot of issues but I did find
a genuinely decent person we've shared
lots of Interest he's a kind of a
Hands-On do-it-yourself kind of guy
um so anyway the Paradox is
how do we reconcile the person who you
know is
has partnered with Glenn Greenwald
uh over the span of many years you know
who reached out to me with compassion at
a moment that he might have taken a
Victory lap for conservatism how do we
reconcile that person with the person
that we thought was so awful
right and what I've come to realize is
that actually a lot of the sense about
Tucker
is a holdover from that prior era
whatever its meaning was the crossfire
era the bow tie era
um and
I think the thing is people assume in
fact you will hear lots of people say oh
people don't change people don't change
right and of course what they really
mean is that change is very difficult
and therefore if you think somebody has
changed radically you're more likely
wrong than right but I think the
evidence that Tucker has changed is
actually
readily apparent and especially in the
aftermath of his de facto firing
I've gone and looked at a number of
things his uh his most recent talk at
the Heritage Foundation was utterly
fascinating absolutely recommend it uh
and some smaller podcast talks that he's
done and he talks about rather like
Glenn Beck he talks about the fact that
he regrets his early behavior in his
career that he feels remorse about it
that he thought he was playing a
destructive role right now that sounds
like a person who has grown and I think
part of what I'm wondering is if
the
the wrap on Tucker Carlson isn't largely
based on the fact that people have not
checked in on not only how he's grown as
a person but also how he has developed
his political understanding right that
his balanced sense that you know if
nobody's if nobody's providing Safe
Harbor for real liberals that somebody
has to do it because conservatism
actually depends on real liberals doing
their job or it's not going to work
right that is a very different story but
you never get there because the
political modality of the day basically
paints somebody with a label and then
persecutes you if you don't trust the
label and go check for yourself right so
you know the the wrap on me of course
was nonsense but what it did
successfully was prevented lots of
people from checking for themselves does
this sound like a white supremacist
right does this sound like a eugenicist
or any of the other
contagious right so anyway that that is
going to become an important
piece of this story which is that there
is a technique that is being used to
keep people from checking in with
dangerous properties like Tucker Carlson
and the technique involves a stigma for
which there is a penalty for checking
for yourself and if people did check for
themselves and many have right they go
watch Dr Carlson today they see these
monologues you know and they realize oh
actually he's alerting me to something
I'm not seeing on other media that's
important and our values aren't so far
apart right that's what you find if you
actually go and check for yourself but
what fraction of the audience just
doesn't because they can't and so anyway
the second Paradox is
did he change or did we have him wrong
or do we have him wrong now right those
of us who have changed our position on
on who he is and I I firmly come out uh
in the belief that he has changed in a
way that his reputation has not caught
up to and I did once ask him about this
um
and the answer was
surprising to me right I said you know
you're just not a good match for what I
see written about you and he sort of had
a general sense that
um
General sense of what's said about him
but he was not in any Deep Way paying
attention to the Daily back and forth
and the scuttlebutt this week on right
so
um anyway that's probably very healthy
very like Joe Rogan who says don't read
the comments
um
okay so you've got a corporation yeah
if you know who you are
and you know what you're doing and you
have some number of close advisors
who your assured will tell you if you
appear to be changing or off or that was
an error or you know whatever whatever
needs to be said to you
why would you drag yourself through the
other stuff
yeah why why would you do it and
I think ultimately in the model we're
going to to find here
there's a question of manipulation right
the audience is clearly manipulated
we've talked about them being
manipulated into not watching for
themselves and formulating their own
opinion but the personalities are also
manipulated too and if you are tuned in
then the point is that is a conduit
through which whatever is operating can
access you and modify what you do in a
way that is not that is useful to it and
not to you and not to your audience so
um there is definitely a strong
piece of that Flavor now what I want to
do is basically throw a number of
principles in together and see if they
don't resolve the ultimate Paradox that
we're discussing which is why would Fox
News burn such an important property
um and I I will I do just want to
Fox recently settled a major lawsuit
um
over
allegations that voting machines were
insecure
and the
idea I find the idea that they fired
Tucker over this Preposterous given his
importance to their business I also
would point out that they settled they
didn't lose a lawsuit so yeah it's a
large number but they chose not to fight
it and this wasn't primarily a Tucker
thing anyway so none of that makes sense
it kind of suffices if you're just
looking for some explanation you can
resort to that but it doesn't it's not
the right order of magnitude uh and you
know so Fox appears to have cut off its
nose nose
yes
I was really trying to change something
else
just listening Heather has suffered a
Furniture malfunction
oh my God yes someone had come in I'm
sorry
it doesn't matter it Furniture
malfunction you can live that down right
it's not a wardrobe malfunction you
don't know
I think I do I do know pretty well okay
um so a couple things I'm just going to
put them on the table and then we'll try
to piece them together yeah
I have argued for
um using the term Goliath to refer to a
force in the universe that one can
detect what is Goliath Goliath is the
force that opposes meaningful change
now
I say that because
first of all changes all around us it's
obvious there's obviously no Force
preventing change but those who have
achieved disproportionate power
rent-seeking Elites who have uh
disproportionate control
disproportionate Security in the future
tend to use that power to prevent
radical shifts because radical shifts
can only take them in the downward
Direction they're very unlikely if
you're at the top you can't go up so
this force is troubled by anything that
threatens to introduce some kind of
change any event horizon uh Beyond which
the future is unpredictable Goliath
opposes that so the prime directive for
Goliath is no meaningful change and
basically meaningful change refers to
the basic flow of well-being power and
wealth right
is Goliath a conspiracy no Goliath is a
hybrid between colluding entities
including you know things like
corporations and political parties
um Departments of
state things like that and emergent
properties right the social phenomena
that emerge in the uh in the social
environment that that buttress the the
current power structure Etc
so
um
that is what I'm going to argue is
underlying a strange move like this a
business operating in a way that is not
business-like that does not appear
oriented towards maximizing shareholder
value over the future and I'm going to
make a weird connection
we see that same odd phenomenon
with the uh Dylan Mulvaney Fiasco with
Anheuser-Busch
and the idea is
ordinarily you would find a property
like Anheuser-Busch very reluctant to
say anything that suggested a strong
political perspective at all because why
would you want to limit your beverage
consumption to people of one ideology
when there might be people of another
ideology who are thirsty also
yeah I guess I'm not I'm not as
compelled that this is the same
um that uh what's going on that your
model
you're asking a question about you know
why Fox appears to be acting in a way
that isn't good for Fox's business
and is the answer the same as the answer
to the question why is Anheuser-Busch
acting in a way that doesn't appear to
be good for anheuser-busch's business
now the VP of whatever Ed Bush who at
Anheuser-Busch who made the decision to
hire Dylan levaney is on some sort of
extended leave of absence now not clear
I haven't kept up with the story I don't
know that it really matters
um but so you know a Anheuser-Busch did
you know put some kind of a corrective
in place but that's actually I don't
think that's not so much the interesting
part the the reason I'm not sure this is
the same
uh is
that trans rights and specifically trans
rights activism is being pushed on us
and somehow a tremendously large number
of Americans at least and other people
in the weird world have have taken this
on as truth
that this is the next civil rights
battle
and
um if if you really believe
that trans rights is is the is the Civil
Rights Battle of the day and that you
also if you were sort of looking around
going like man you know the 60s must
have been an amazing time to be alive
you know really fighting for the thing
that should have been the case all along
you know Civil Rights was finally
happening we were finally getting there
that wasn't especially in retrospect
right
um civil rights wasn't a political
position it was a human position this is
this is like you know this is this is
what we all should have recognized and
we understand to some degree why we
didn't but here we are finally catching
up to our our shared humanity and let's
go but trans rights
um aren't like that sorry no for a
number of reasons and we've talked about
it a lot
um but in part because this is a you
know opt-in you don't have to do
anything but
um you know put on a woman's face and
you get to claim to be a woman
and uh maybe maybe more to the point uh
you just
well
boy I feel like I'm trying to go in too
many directions here I think I think
you're you're what you're saying makes
sense but I think in some sense it's the
cover story
and this is the place where but but it
may be but it may work because it may
work because you've actually got people
convinced that if
um you know pick your hero if Martin
Luther King Jr or Malcolm X were the
civil rights leaders
um that we all needed in the 60s uh
maybe Dylan Mulvaney is the leader that
uh that we all need in the 2020s and
that's you know reprehensible on its
base right um but I think a number of
people actually believe that and so you
know maybe the maybe something
underlying you know like why is the
trans rights agenda
cruising with such alacrity through all
of our lives uh is of course a bigger
and maybe more interesting question but
um people have compelled themselves for
uh because they they really think that
not only are they on the right side of
History here but that you couldn't
possibly there is no possible
explanation for being on the other side
of it right and that's why it is a
beautiful bludgeon right because if you
can successfully get people to make one
Leap that this is the same as uh the
fight against Jim Crow or the fight for
uh the freedom of people to be openly
gay
um if you understand this is that fight
then you can look at the map and you can
say well oh I know who the people are
who you know uh you know
tried to block the schoolhouse from
black kids attending and I'm going to be
on the other side of that fight I
remember what their angry faces looked
like right exactly I don't want to be
remembered by history so people are
terrified of being on the wrong side of
history and
um they have falsely been led to believe
that this is a story they already know
it just has a new subject right but I
would point out Dylan Mulvaney and
Anheuser-Busch
that's one example of something that we
see again and again and again right
Twitter was another such example right
Twitter was throwing people off for
saying perfectly mundane things right
now there was a conservative bias in who
it was punishing but of course it
punished all sorts of people it punished
uh Unity 2020 when we were really just
trying to elect uh courageous capable
Patriots to the White House right you
know what may have been a quixotic
attempt to do it but the point was
something about Twitter was behaving in
exactly the opposite way that you would
imagine that a social media site should
and all of them do right a social media
site is in competition for attention
eyeballs people willing to spend time on
Twitter why is it throwing off users who
like uh Megan Murphy are simply
asserting that men aren't women right
even if the people at Twitter disagree
with that
this is a perspective for which there is
an audience who would come to Twitter
and make Twitter wealthier because the
overall Twitter audience is bigger same
thing obviously with YouTube
um right you know where we remain we
remain demonetized uh for closing around
two years now
um but I just saw today or yesterday
that I guess Kim Iverson had an
interview with Robert F Kennedy Jr who
is yes running for president and this
interview was not even that recent right
um but they they took it down the
striker Channel yep um for you know for
daring to speak with someone who is
running for president because he suffers
from wrong think
you know who else had had Robert Kennedy
Jr on
Tucker yeah yeah
um so this is going to so I did on the
list of you know corporations Behaving
Badly or weirdly you know Gillette we've
now forgotten uh Gillette did some
gender weird thing uh several years ago
and created a huge uproar and you know
again how about Hershey's for uh right
Women's National whatever the month was
but
um and then I think it was daily wire he
came out with their own brand of
chocolate she her without nuts and he
him with nuts if you need someone to
tell you which one's which it's the
wrong chocolate for you um right so yep
okay we've got a phenomenon corporations
behaving paradoxically with respect to
what they're supposed to be doing which
is making money and more to the point
um their fiduciary responsibility to
their shareholders is to put those
shareholders in a good position so why
are they politicizing their products
when you know conservatives and liberals
need to shave drink beer or you know
whatever it is or discuss things online
all of this is so paradoxical now did
you say conservatives and liberals need
to drink beer yes well
they both drink up here and therefore
you might imagine that a beer producer
wouldn't want to piss off part of that
audience in advance and in fact you're
not claiming it as a human right I mean
look this used no
well
I'm now in a predicament because I can't
drink beer and so if it's a human right
maybe I'm being oppressed but because of
the gluten because of the the gluten
yeah but I would point out in the past
let's take the Coors Corporation now in
my family it was well understood that
Coors was a reactionary family
right but the brand the family that
owned the brand was reactionary right
and so there was some like grumbling
about people drinking Coors because it's
like why would you enrich those folks
right but Coors wasn't being political
in their ads they were doing the
opposite they were obscuring the fact
that you know or Knott's Berry Farm or
any of these entities which for those
who didn't grow up in Southern
California was a like the third
amusement park after
um Disneyland and Magic Mountain yeah it
was it was the The Circus Vargas of of
amusement parks but but anyway the point
is Brands used to go out of their way
not to connect their politics with their
product because money is money right so
Paradox is why in the current ERA are
these corporations behaving so weirdly
and firing their top star and
you know all of these things and of
course business people are currently
shouting at their
television no we're not on television
there are screens or their speakers
because the answer in some sense is
obvious the proximate answer it is ESG
right now ESG stands for environment no
environment social and government social
and governance right
which is
so ESG yeah I'm gonna show a little
video maybe we should just do that it
will it will uh explain itself okay uh
Zach cue the e s before you show this so
what's the what's the source on this
this is uh CFI which is some sort of uh
like a we're going to get back to what
ESG is but I believe it is like a
ratings agency it's basically a
um a a
facilitator of ESG in the market cfis
yeah
yeah you might have to give me 10
seconds ESG stands for environmental
social and governance you can think of
it as an analysis framework to help
measure and quantify the degree to which
an organization is operating in a
sustainable manner
environmental assessment criteria help
stakeholders understand an
organization's impact on the environment
and the climate like its greenhouse gas
emissions and its management teams
stewardship over natural resources like
fresh water
while understanding environmental risk
and impact is a big part of the ESG
framework the concept of sustainability
in this context extends well beyond just
the environment the ass pillar social
examines an organization's social impact
it seeks to understand how well
leadership manages relationships with
stakeholders including Fair wages for
workers generating positive outcomes in
the communities where they operate and
taking accountability for the actions
and inactions of supply chain Partners
in other parts of the world
the GE as we know is governance so how
is the firm LED and managed stakeholders
are increasingly taking note that a
healthy corporate governance function
can make or break progress in the E and
the S Realms but can even create
existential threats for business
operations more broadly
ESG as we know it evolved from a number
of older sustainability themed acts and
Frameworks including EHS environmental
health and safety and CSR or corporate
social responsibility but these older
Frameworks took more of a philanthropic
approach implying that management teams
should do good because it's the right
thing to do what's somewhat unique about
ESG is that it looks at these issues
through the lens of business risk and
opportunity which tends to resonate more
clearly with the investment Community
these rapidly changing market and
non-market conditions have created the
ESG landscape as we see it today
this includes the emergence of ESG
rating agencies ESG scores mandatory
public reporting often called ESG
disclosure and countless sustainability
themed funds and investment strategies
all right
um let me just say that actually uh
the visuals that go along with that in
the absence of the sound are in some
ways even more disturbing it has a kind
of a mesmerizing we are the good people
and these are the things that we will do
the thing so you literally showed this
to me within minutes of us starting and
I was only listening so that's the first
time I saw the visuals and I took some
notes and I thought that my my
overriding sense of this video was that
there's there's no specifics
right
um that you know how is it that
um these scores these you know the
agency is the scores the mandatory
reporting the funds the investment
strategies are being decided on like
what what are what are the values that
lie just below the surface and we we
hear for instance
um
leadership managing relationship with
stakeholders are taking responsibility
for the actions and inactions of supply
chain Partners in other parts of the
world
taking responsibility for the inactions
of supply chain Partners in other parts
of the world
what thing that your supply chain
partners are the parts of the world
might they do or not do that would
prompt you to be interested and you know
so they they mentioned climate and fresh
water and that's about the only specific
things that they even
point to at all here well I want a steel
man
ESG before we
um
reveal what it actually is yeah okay
because there are a couple
first of all let me just say as a
lifelong Progressive
I believe it is actually
philosophically
all but certain that our top priority
ought to be sustainability properly
defined
that before we get to anything else
Humanity should never deliver the Next
Generation a lesser world than the one
that we were handed right because if you
start doing that it's a very short ride
and there are lots of competitive
dynamics that will produce that so I
understand the devil is in the details
of defining what it means not to deliver
the Next Generation a lesser world is
not an easy thing to do so
operationalizing that is not something
I'm even claiming can be well done but
philosophically speaking Our obligation
to Future Generations is something we
are falling down on and sustainability
if we were reasonable and just to use
common parlance
sustainability should be our top uh
priority before we get to anything else
um and there is a game theory problem in
sustainability which I won't go deeply
into but it's a very well understood
problem that goes by the name of
collective action in uh in academic
circles and basically what it means is
that if each party pursues the best
uh course of action for its own
well-being that the global well-being is
decreased by lots of phenomena in other
words
um the ability of any Corporation to
reduce pollution enough to make a
difference is Tiny uh and so
um there's no motivation to cut your own
uh emissions because if your competitor
doesn't then they come out ahead and so
years ago I did a talk
a tedx talk called the personal
responsibility vortex in which I
basically said if in the absence of an
enforcement mechanism if you live your
principles you will actually put your
principles people set your principles
back and that the
um the right way to advance your
principles is to do whatever course of
action makes the most sense including
leaves you healthiest and all of those
things but not to you know buy products
for the good of the planet but to buy
the right products that are priced
correctly and use the Surplus to move
the world in the direction of the values
that you hold rather than try to do it
by shopping uh in a particular way
because if you did try to leave a
sustainable world then you couldn't
Avail yourself of almost any of the
products that I mean you know should you
know this microphone is undoubtedly
made of materials that I wouldn't like
how they were sourced and produced in
the conditions of the workers so am I
not allowed to have a microphone and by
not having a microphone I can't reach
the audience and tell them about the
personal responsibility Vortex so am I
better off making a compromise at the
microphone and being able to reach an
audience clearly
so in any case ESG
is built around some correct
logic and values the correct logic and
values of values are we want a world
that functions well that's fair that is
inclusive that is sustainable
and the stated goals of ESG that's it
um
and it is true that the market itself
does not produce sustainable outcomes it
does not produce Fair outcomes right it
produces something below that level and
so a coordinated effort is in principle
not a crazy idea but in this case what
ESG is is an excuse
to Marshall power in the direction of a
political
objective which is not stated and so for
example let's take the
the question of
uh well e e and ESG right environment
okay environment well we all want the
environment protected breakfast said
that the Top Value ought to be
sustainability so presumably he's on
board with 15-minute cities uh but no I
am not 15-minute cities are an excuse
for control over the population I am
dead set against those things but if
some entity decides that oh well
sustainability is good and therefore
15-minute cities are good and therefore
we want corporations who are advancing
the cause of 15-minute cities and they
get a higher rating which means that
when I look at the box of whatever it
says that they're a Better Corporation
right then the point is the political
agenda is using this thing as a weapon
and that's what I meant by the lack of
specificity that they that they vaguely
State some values that in in principle
in very vague terms we all should be
able to get behind
um and this I guess this is the analogy
to the Dylan levating things like well
it's it's civil rights we can all get
behind that can't we and then they say
now you don't worry your pretty little
heads about any of the specifics and
we'll take care of the
operationalization part of this process
because that's really that's you know
that's inside baseball you wouldn't want
to know and uh as it turns out we really
do want to know we have to know and you
have to stop until you start telling us
what it is that you're doing because
this is bad right now here's the thing
that I realized in thinking through this
ESG is social credit for corporations
and I'm sure others have noticed that
but
they said that oh they do okay
well they say scores but the point is
those of us who know what the Chinese
social credit system is
fear such a thing being instituted in
the west we fear it being interested
instituted through uh Central Bank
digital currencies for example all of
which is very plausible and on the March
the idea that this has a wing over in
corporate space that is going to operate
through ratings agencies that are for
example going to decide
that trans rights
are a good now our trans rights are good
yes up until they are in conflict with
somebody else's rights but the idea that
a ratings agency is going to notice that
uh a trans person may have struggles in
the world and not notice that children
are being uh sterilized under the banner
of trans rights right which side is good
right are the I would say that the
people who are protecting children are
actually doing the more important job
and so it's not obvious in which
direction that score should go but it is
very obvious which direction it will go
and so why does this exist right well
I'm going to argue and you should
probably be sitting down for this I know
that chair can pull surprise us on you
but
um that was all me yeah
you can't just go randomly flipping
levers on chairs right
in any case the reason that this ESG
thing is happening in my opinion is that
it is a facilitator of this new kind of
fascism that we are seeing and I'm not
exaggerating when I say fascism
so fascism is of course an ideology that
has reared its ugly head many times
the sin qua non the central feature of
fascism is the uniting of government and
corporate power and ESG as a social
credit uh system for corporations
is basically aligning corporations with
a hand down from above set of values
now handed down from above set of values
if the government functioned in a truly
Democratic way so that those values were
really a reflection of what voters
believed and wanted that would be one
thing it would still be fallible but it
would at least be defensible
but when it's being handed down by
something that is not functioning in a
democratic way in the slightest it is
absolutely terrifying right I would also
point out
is it just the corporate uh government
Fusion that appears fascist no fascists
also take a militaristic view of the
world in other words
I've argued that the distinction between
um nationalism and patriotism is that
nationalism is basically uh what your
country can do for you using your
country as a bludgeon and patriotism is
the willingness to sacrifice for your
country there are essentially opposites
they have a shared connotation in the
mind but it's wrong so this
corporate government partnership or
Fusion this fascist Fusion has taken a
decidedly militaristic view of the world
it is
um
effectively coercing other nations and
you know you can see the coercion in
covid policy for example why did the
whole world take the same approach to
covet why did you know why are we
struggling to find exceptions where we
can go to measure a different policy it
wasn't obvious what we should do from
the beginning there should be a huge
diversity of policies but it's all
centralized through you know the who for
example which is about to gain more
power in this milieu well I mean
obviously there's attention and uh I I
I'm surprised
to find myself about to be arguing that
you know we
as we said throughout covid
um you know not not this product with
this disease with this government like
no mandates know-how under these three
conditions
um but can you imagine a pathogen so
horrifying and so rapidly spreading that
a global response was uh was actually
the thing that needed to happen I can
I can that we don't have that
infrastructure in place and now
having lived through covid I am you know
bereft of solutions I guess like I feel
like oh I would have thought that we
should have had something in place in
case of such a situation and now I see
that no such no such situation no such
entity could possibly be trustworthy uh
well
uh it remains to be seen whether a
conceivable entity could be trustworthy
what we know is that no entity that is
on the map is trustworthy and therefore
it puts but all future entities will
also be made up of people right but
they're you know I don't think the game
theory is insurmountable I don't think
good governance is impossible but I
don't think good governance is
impossible I am not compelled that good
Global governance is possible or uh
let's put it this way we are depending
on the fact that somebody can come up
with a scheme but the solutions of the
18th century are not up to the challenge
that is true what we have is a landscape
full of malignant entities and so
I agree I'd love to have a global public
health authority that actually was
interested in public health had enough
humility to figure out when it was
making an error and stop making it was
inclined to recommend the obvious in
order to improve public health and we
have none of those things right even the
who continues to recommend as it was
doing before covid through covet and now
um that if you go outside uh while the
sun is high you absolutely must cover
yourself in sunscreen or clothing
because the sun is poison yeah and I
don't know they use that language but
you know they just
it's not them but then who is it which
is insane yeah but all right so let's
begin to tighten this model up a little
bit you've got ESG which is being used
to align corporations that are not
naturally aligned it could be used
something like it could be used to align
them in the direction of things you know
solving Game Theory problems but this is
really functioning as an excuse to align
them around uh a particular set of
signals that they are on board with the
crypto fascist move that we are now
collectively being dragged into
and so along the lines of you know why
would Gillette or Anheuser-Busch uh
thumbits knows at some huge fraction of
its uh Market why would Fox News burn
Tucker Carlson and his audience in a way
that is infuriating right people who
would ordinarily you know if Tucker had
quit would still be Fox News viewers are
enraged at this and as they should be
okay so why would they do that and right
I was talking to Zach about this um in
the car this morning
and he uh reminded me of
a concept uh it actually
the first time I said it was
the last I think it was the last time I
met my uh the last class I taught at
Evergreen we met in a park maybe it
wasn't the very last time the second the
last time I met them met in a park
because it wasn't safe to be on campus
and I had been invited to go on Joe
Rogan's program and I barely knew who
Joe Rogan was
um these people of course knew who Joe
Rogan was because they were a good bit
younger and so he was an important
person in in their lives
and anyway I gave them a little talk
about the oddness that their Professor
was going on this apparently important
program and
why that would be happening based on
what was going on at their school and
all of this and I said to them I said
take very careful notes on what's going
on we will not be back this way again
all right I knew that this was a one-way
trip that it
this this was not something that was
going to be put back together it
couldn't be
um and so anyway why would Fox News burn
Tucker Carlson in this audience
because they're playing a new dynamic in
which they know they won't be back this
way again they don't need Tucker over
they need to have Tucker Carlson gone
more than they need him for some
nebulous future in which they're playing
their traditional role that's the thing
that I want to surface here is that they
are actually
um
and I you know there's some good news in
this I know I'm not the good news guy
but there is some good news in this
because in order for them
to have taken the step of getting rid of
Tucker
two things are true one they've revealed
themselves right they have alerted us
that there is something on the March
that is behaving very strangely and does
not appear to be just a simple
Corporation trying to you know
get an audience right it's something
else so be aware there's something on
the March that's one thing but here's
the other thing
why did they reveal themselves in this
uh in this way
they did it because they are insecure
and that is good news
the fact is they are concerned about
something enough that they had to make
them and I think I know what it is
okay maybe I'm not I don't I don't see
why a move uh that is a paradox
is inherently a reveal of insecurity it
could just be the next step no it could
be the next step but the thing is if
if you want to claim that people are you
know paranoid then not making moves that
they can spot and say that's a very odd
thing for a media company to do to go
after its biggest you know chunk of
audience and enrage them right that's a
weird thing to do so why would they do
that rather than continue to hide if
they were feeling secure it wouldn't be
worth making that aggressive move well
no I mean again I would say it could be
about feeling secure feeling insecure
but it also could be about being on the
move they could feel secure but also be
on the Move in pursuit of something I
believe they are but I believe they have
been forced out of hiding in some sense
that the point is they can't just simply
March where they're going that there's
actually something they know that
they're in in danger and I think in part
they know that they're in danger because
Trump revealed that their control the
duopoly's ability to shut out anything
meaningful is not complete
um which then raises this odd paradox
you had RFK Jr
going on Tucker Carlson's program right
this is
supposed to be matter and antimatter
right this is a died in the wool liberal
from uh famously liberal important
family going on the program of arch
conservative Tucker Carlson to announce
his bid for the Democratic nomination
for the president and that is a
remarkable fact in and of itself and the
fact that Tucker Carlson is of course
hospitable
is very troubling why because this is
awesome what do you mean troubling it's
troubling to the forces that to Goliath
it's troubling because
um
because effectively why would people who
are politically so far apart be finding
common cause why would why would this be
anything other than a very contentious
interview in which Tucker Carlson is
trying to get to the bottom of rfk's
liberalism and show it to be false why
would it be uh you know a a meeting of
uh
of of unity and Alignment well because
they're both Patriots
and the point is Goliath is not
patriotic at all Goliath wants to
maintain maintain control and the
illusion of democracy but cannot afford
democracy and so here's my contention
just to sum it up
Bobby Kennedy is terrifying to the DNC
because well he should be in office he
would do the job that Democrats are
supposed to do and that is uh in direct
conflict with the dnc's business model
and the DNC is not supposed to have a
business model but it very clearly does
and so it panders to its voters but its
real constituents are not voters it's
powerful rent-seeking Elites
Bobby Kennedy would have the bully
pulpit in the role of President and
considerable power and it is much more
terrifying to the DNC than uh something
like Trump in fact Trump is good for the
DNC because the DNC does not have an a
valid argument in favor of electing its
candidates other than Trump right so
they fear
uh RFK Jr and so here's the point RFK Jr
goes on Tucker Carlson's program and uh
reveals in showing up there and having a
cordial conversation about a political
about a bid for the presidency
um
the danger to Goliath and here's what I
think is afoot
Tucker Carlson's position
has been very similar to what happened
in podcast world over the course of
the last
four or five years
although he sat in a mainstream Media
Care
his position was quite heterodox
and
the point is if you were going to make a
move in which you were going to somehow
learn the lesson that Goliath should
learn from kovid and realize that
although it can it owned all of the big
media properties that it could not
maintain control over the narrative and
that truth emerged not fully but in you
know across lab leak across repurposed
drugs vaccine safety and Effectiveness
the proliferation of variants all of
these things the actual narrative broke
through the media control because
Goliath did not understand what podcast
world was or why anybody would listen to
somebody in a man cave or any of those
things
Persona or sauna for example so
the point is
let's say that that's going to happen
over the course of the next electoral
cycle through the presidential election
that's going to happen that we are going
to have a battle in which the mainstream
media is all going to sing from the same
Hymnal and podcast world is going to
reveal the insanity of that Hymnal and
worse Twitter being a free property
because musk has freed it is going to be
a place where we can discuss the Paradox
of why the mainstream media is focused
on a narrative that's obviously not true
right
and you might have a like an actual
presidential figure running for office
right not a uh you know a wrecking ball
like Trump but somebody who actually
aspires to write the ship of State
so
my contention is Tucker
couldn't remain in a mainstream seat
because what he is doing crosses over
into the mainstream and if it is shunted
over into podcast world then whatever
this force is can I don't know if it's
going to use isps or uh credit card
processors or whatever it's going to use
against podcast world where some
industrial strength propaganda campaign
that learned the lesson of covet and you
know proceeds to do a better job but the
point is
Tucker had to be shoved out because his
mainstreamness was out it did not fit
whatever is coming
and I would just say the a prediction of
this model
is that the other person on the other
side of the aisle who fits that same
description uh
Don Lemon no I don't Don Lemon is a very
different property that's what I thought
so who you're thinking of Bill Maher oh
that Bill Maher is also a heterodox
person with a large audience sitting in
a mainstream seat and you know it's
funny I had that thought and then I
happened on Twitter I didn't know Elon
Musk had been uh interviewed by Bill
Maher but I think this must have
happened yesterday
um
and anyway they talk they don't they
allude to this jokingly that bill my
that you know Elon is the Grim Reaper or
the Typhoid Mary uh of uh talk shows
that you know uh Tucker interviewed him
and now Tucker is out of a job
I don't know that's the one I know but
um but they joked maybe Bill Maher is
next but I wonder if Bill Maher either
something works to chase in Bill Maher
which I hope is impossible I hope he's
just a free man and uh can uh evade
whatever controls they are but if not
you might wonder if his mainstream seat
might be in Jeopardy in the upcoming uh
year because of the election if
if all of this is true and I think you
know I I don't see anything to object to
in your analysis except for the
um except for your contention that this
necessarily reveals a lack of security
on the part of fox
um I think it's even more important that
uh for lack of a better descriptor
podcast world non-mainstream media world
stop the infighting already so you
mentioned uh podcasters and Twitter
and obviously in in written
word substack is the main Contender
there and the shenanigans the Elon Musk
continues to pull with substack are
untenable like that that is that is uh
you know
breaching Unwritten unspoken agreements
sort of gentlemen's agreements that I
think we assumed that we had and that
really
um should be should should go back into
place uh because you know we're in it
run it for society here like this is
this this is this is big Goliath is
super powerful and as much as you know a
single billionaire like musk is going to
be very very powerful himself
if podcast world and uh Bobby Kennedy Jr
and Twitter and Rumble and locals and
sub stack
can stop the infighting then we have a
better chance so at the moment
um just just as a reminder briefly
uh Twitter had stopped allowing any
substack links to be um to to be clicked
through on at all you got an error
message this might be dangerous stuff
and that actually stopped happening
while we were talking about it on air a
couple weeks ago
um but quietly and I've heard no one
talk about this what has replaced that
that insane policy is now you can you
can link to a sub stack but it just
shows up as a line of indecipherable hot
linkable text and the social media
assets don't come along with it so you
don't get the image that comes along
with the thing and it and it's it's it's
not interesting to share and so it's not
so stuff is not being shared so you know
come on stop that there is no reason
beyond the really Petty competitive
stuff between a future a Twitter
property and what is established as
substack and the Future substack
Property you know notes on Twitter yeah
going after each other competitively uh
but you know this this is not helpful
so I'm going to propose something the uh
the Unholy
Alliance built around ESG
has to have a countervailing force and
the countervailing force is those
properties that are actually built to
protect the values around the West
around which the West is founded most
importantly a free exchange of ideas
um and so what I would propose is that
the countervailing force the honorable
alignment and I'm not suggesting these
businesses aren't in competition but the
honorable Force should be the internet
Beyond the Wall
on the internet Beyond the Wall the Free
People of the internet need to look out
for each other we may have our
differences but we need to look out for
each other because the real enemy is
Goliath
and
that is uh that is enough of a hazard to
to the West that
um all of the other stuff is secondary
so yes Elon I would ask you
um maybe there's stuff we can't see but
please
uh be mindful of the fact that the
Public Square cannot be a monopoly
that's not how it's going to work that's
right
uh so we have to go
um I hope that spring is still happening
the next time we see you guys
um because we have been seeing some
amazing springy things with foxes and
swallows and ladybugs and Eagles and I'd
like to talk about that perhaps next
time I don't think we have time now
excellent
um we will be back on Tuesday
May
as my calendar think it's March May 9th
at 2 p.m Pacific and then the following
Saturday May 13th at the usual time
unless it's going to be a little while
before you see us again but
um but there's lots of other things to
do again it's spring and if you're in
the southern hemisphere it's fall get
outside while you still can with short
sleeves on right
um
so yeah uh thank you as always for
joining us and until we see you next be
good to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside be well
everyone
[Music]